[Music]  Disney has a movie coming out their  latest movie the odd life of Timothy  green just came out I think couple days  ago and it has upset some parents they  say the life story of a boy who  magically sprouts from a garden has an  ending that is too sad for young  children and I gotta say my kids were  excited I took them I have to agree I  don't think this is a cool thing to see  [Music]  hi I'm Timothy something you need to  know about me I came from the garment  work as  [Applause]  [Music]  are you even looking her job there's  lots of jobs for me no no ma he's right  here let's take a look oh here's one  half man half plant wanted to run  successful insurance burn  [Music]  oh my god go ahead pick one what's that  time we've got bark beetles incurable  dammit  well that was a lot of life  [Applause]  [Music]  you